well more than a decade ago Channing
Tatum starred with Amanda Bynes in she's
the man Amanda says that she actually
launched his career she also says she's
clean and sober now after years of
struggle good for her and only nischelle
Turner got Channing's reaction
amanda Bynes said the moment she laid
eyes on you she said that guy's a star I
love her I'm so happy to cease like
killing it again and just back back on
the right she's so talented and so
special and I think it's so impossible
when you start at such a young age to
keep like perspective stuff I'm not
really good at talking to girls why
you're hot what I love you men in our
video line well if a man is responsible
for all this goodness we thank you but
the big question is seven years after
filming Magic Mike can chanting still
pull off these moves how dusted off is
Old Faithful look it's right I want to
say it's like riding a bicycle but we
caught up with Channing and his hot
stripper posse at the premiere of Magic
Mike live London do you ever think about
down the line flipping the script insane
what about I do magic Mikayla look I
would love to do that Jada actually
pitch that and and we spent a little
while it's it's complicated doing a
female like version it's a very
sensitive time for that specifically and
to do it right is like threading a
needle
your mom and your sister seen this show
by the way it was weird enough seeing
like seeing the first two movies I'm
sitting next to my parents and I'm like
oh man I didn't think this through like
this is this is a horrible idea
[Music]